After you've developed, tested,
and launched a great app,
your next biggest challenge
is to grow a valuable audience
of interested users.
Hi, I'm Frederic from
the Google Play Team.
With new tools in the Google
Play Developer Console,
we're making it
easier to understand
the performance of user
acquisition channels,
and we are making it possible to
acquire new users across Google
networks.
Imagine you've developed
a racing game called RPM.
Your beta testers loved it.
And so you launched
publicly on Google Play.
Once users started
downloading your app,
you start asking yourself
important questions.
Where are the users coming from?
How did they hear
about the game?
What prompted them
to install it?
And which of these users
are most likely to make
an in-app purchase?
You can now find answers
to these questions
in the user
acquisition performance
report in the Google
Play Developer Console.
For new user acquisition
performance reports
summarizes how users discover
your app and spend money.
You can find out how many users
visited your store listing
page, installed the
app, and eventually made
one or more purchases.
Looking at this information
on your user funnel,
you can choose areas
to optimize or plan
store listing experiments to
explore different options.
For getting Discovery
Channels, we
show traffic coming from
the Play Store and outside
of it, such as users finding
your app via Google Search.
And if your marketing gurus are
using UTM tags on their links,
the performance report
also tracks those
and will tell you exactly
how each of your channels
are doing.
Now that you know where
users are coming from,
you want to start
acquiring new users, which
is critical to your success.
There are many ways
to acquire new users.
One common way is to
pay for app install ads.
That's where the new universal
app campaigns come in.
They are the easiest way
to promote your Android
app to interested users
across Google Play, Google
Search, YouTube, and the
Google Display Network.
You can do this directly
from the Developer Console.
It takes just a few clicks
to get a campaign up
and running within your budget.
Let's see how it
works in practice.
When you open the Developer
Console, navigate to your game
and select the User
Acquisition tab.
From there, choose to
create a new campaign.
The ad creation form
is already pre-filled
using the existing
place to listing assets,
like your app icon, short
description, and promo video.
If you want, you can tweak with
promotional messaging a bit.
All that's left is
choosing a maximum budget
and how much you're willing
to pay for an install.
If you're publishing
your game globally,
you know that each market
monetizes differently.
Cost per install might be
different between the United
States and Spain, for instance.
We recommend that you
explore what cost per install
makes sense in
each country you're
targeting on Google Play.
And also think about how much
you earn from the typical user
in each country.
It's important to experiment
with your cost per install
to see how it affects
the number of conversions
that your campaign generates.
After completing
the form, that's it.
The first app promotion
campaign for RPM is ready to go.
Google Play will run a
fully automated campaign
across Google networks.
This includes Google.com web
search, AdMob on Google Display
Network banners and mobile apps,
video placements in YouTube,
and even search ads in
the Play Store itself.
We do the hard
work to figure out
which ad placement
works best for your app
and which users to target.
Zero optimization work for you.
It's why we call these
universal app campaigns.
It's the fastest way
to start advertising
your app with Google.
With the performance report
you can understand and optimize
your acquisition channels,
whether organic or paid.
And with universal
app campaigns you'll
be able to find users interested
in your app in no time.
Next you should
check out our video
in Store Listing Experiments.
You will learn how to run AB
test on your Play Store listing
and increase your installs.
This could multiply the
effect of all your user
acquisition efforts.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]